el presidente de tanzania john mcfall y
murió este miércoles en dar es salaam la
capital económica del país africano
el mandatario de 61 años falleció tras
padecer una enfermedad cardiaca con la
que lidiaba desde años atrás la
vicepresidenta
samia zulú informó sobre el deceso
ciudadanos lamento informarles que hoy
17 de marzo de 2021 a las seis de la
tarde perdimos a nuestro valiente líder
el presidente de tanzania el honorable
ión mago falling full y mago juli un
negacionista del coi 19 había despertado
sospechas por su desaparición de la
escena pública desde el pasado 27 de
febrero cuando se le vio por última vez
en la posesión de su jefe de gabinete
por este motivo la oposición promovió
rumores en torno a un posible contagio
de coronavirus sin confirmarse nada de
manera oficial al principio de la
pandemia el presidente desestimó la
gravedad de la enfermedad invitando a
los ciudadanos a rezar por el bienestar
colectivo
debido a esta negación del gobierno se
desconoce la situación sanitaria de
tanzania desde abril de 2020
no tengan miedo y no se dejen intimidar
por el coronavirus sigamos trabajando
dios está con nosotros y nos salvarán a
colom a mago fu lee casado y padre de
tres hijos fue elegido presidente en
octubre de 2015
desde entonces se caracterizó por su
lucha contra la corrupción y sus
políticas de línea dura sin embargo su
imagen se vio afectada por la censura a
medios de comunicación y por denuncias
de acoso a sus detractores políticos en
el parlamento